good morning Hank it's Wednesday May
18th 2011 also known as button your
button day Hank in the last 24 hours I
finished the big revision of my novel
and I also watched your poetic
commencement address and it made me
think a lot about education and why
we're alive and stuff right so when we
think about education we often think
about a soft hard continuum on the far
edge of hard you have mathematics which
you know there's only one right answer
and everything's about numbers and data
and then on the far edge of the soft
side you have the study of literature
where everything is about you know what
it means to be a person in a world full
of other people and how to understand
ourselves in history and all that boring
stuff you know what I'm talking about
Hank history is pretty soft physics is
pretty hard biology is somewhere in the
middle because you know it involves
adorable baby pigs but they're dead and
you have to dissect them psychology
thinks that it's hard but it's actually
soft economics thinks that it's soft but
it's actually hard you know what I'm
talking about
right except in my opinion Hank that
continuum is complete and utter Warner
Chilcott so ain't when you study
mathematics you're really studying two
things first you're studying
mathematical language so the simplest
kind of mathematical language is that
when we talk about the number seven
we're not only talking about seven
Donuts or seven pairs of pants we're
talking about the abstracted idea of
seven and then when you get to algebra
the language of mathematics suddenly
involves letters and the language of
math gets more and more complex as you
learned which is why when I read
something by Brotherhood 2.0 resident
mathematician Daniel Biss I feel
illiterate so that's the first thing
you're doing when you study math the
second thing is that you're attempting
to understand the universe right I mean
I don't want to overstate the matter but
that's basically what we're doing
ultimately the reason that we have to
know that the square root of four is two
is because it helps us to build
cathedrals and think about space and
make out with people but more on that in
a second right so we study math too the
twin reasons of wanting to learn
mathematical language and wanting to
understand our place in the universe
which turns out to be precisely why we
also study literature to worry about
language and to understand our place in
the universe which by the way and gets
to the thing that makes me angry is than
the entire world which is when people
say that there is only one right answer
in math but that every answer is equally
correct in literature that's just bunk
first off there is often more than one
correct answer in math and secondly not
every
they're equally correct in literature
science might have a guy for instance
Hank if you think that The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn is a pro-slavery novel
you're wrong
you're as wrong as you are if you think
that the square root of 4 is
strawberries right so students of the
world I want you to look at me for a
second most of the questions that you're
asking in your literature classes are
not that interesting like the question
of whether the author intended that
symbol or that metaphor let me tell you
as an author who intends symbols and
metaphors that question is not
interesting it doesn't matter if when I
was writing Paper Towns I wanted the
great white wall of tau to reference the
great white wall of whale and Moby Dick
the great white wall of cow and/or whale
isn't there for you to think about
authorial intent it's there for you to
think about nature's seemingly absolute
apathy toward individual humans and what
the heroic response to that apathy is
and the reason that reading critically
like reading for theme and metaphor and
symbol is important is because those
things are ways into the big interesting
questions many of which are the same
questions that math is trying to answer
Hank the vast majority of us imagine
ourselves as like literature people or
else like math people but the truth is
that the massive parallel process are
known as the human brain is neither a
literature organ or a math organ it is
both and more Hank putting aside
learning for learnings sake I'd argue
that understanding the universe and its
inhabitants is helpful in pretty much
every human endeavor which is why nerds
in my experience are more likely to
understand special relativity and also
more likely to be good at kissing so
math people let me tell you that
imaginary stories can be every bit as
intellectually engaging as imaginary
numbers and literature people I am here
to tell you that set theory is every bit
as fascinating and moving and beautiful
as the Great Gatsby
Hank I'll see you on Monday is it Friday
no that's Wednesday isn't it Hank I'll
see you on Friday
god I'm so bad at days I really anchor
days of the week math or literature
they're both